- [Kelly] I'm so intrigued.
I've never done anything like this.
- [Theresa] Okay, great.
So, um,
(sighs)
so there is a mother
energy that is present
so if your mom is not departed,
it would be like a grandmother or an aunt
or someone that was like a mother to you.
- It could literally be any of those
'cause everyone died before me (laughs).
- Oh okay, but right now
- Yeah.
your mom is here in the physical world?
- My mom is alive, yeah.
- Okay.
- You're very fortunate
because you have not
lost a lot of people here
in the physical world.
- Yeah, I don't know many
people that have passed away.
- Right, well can I talk
about the dad that's departed.
- Oh my dad did die.
Oh I don't know him.
- Oh!
- Oh yeah I'm sorry.
- Oh okay.
I was gonna just ask you about pie.
- I love pie.
- That's what they told me!
They go Kelly loves pie!
- I love pie.
They showed me cherry pie
and I'm like okay,
what am I supposed to say
with that? I don't have a -
- Oh that's funny, cherry
pie's my sister thing,
but she's the one he's
probably trying to talk to.
- Well listen.
- We don't know each other.
- But you have to understand
your dad could not take responsibility
for things in his life here
in the physical world.
- Not a one.
His soul is stepping forward and saying
I know what you felt.
I know what you went through
and for that I am sorry.
- Oh I've already forgiven. So I'm good.
But I'm not like mad at
it, if he can hear me.
- No! No no no!
- Oh I was like...
- That's not what this is about.
- Okay.
- You have to understand
it's where someone
if they hurt us or disappoint us
if only if the soul has learned the lesson
to see things differently,
they can come through and say that, so...
- All right!
I'll tell my sister.
- For your dad to be
able to come through...
- Oh yeah Candice did lose someone, yes.
- Who are you?
- [Candice] I'm Candice.
- She's my stylist.
- Oh hi, nice to meet you.
- So nice to meet you.
- Oh my god, my very first
thing you said was mother
and I was thinking my life,
but her mother recently passed.
That's right!
- [Candice] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Were you watching her breath at the end?
- Okay, so,
your mom just says to me, she says
please tell my daughter I
know how much she misses me
- (whispers) I do.